all right welcome to cbs this morning
and we begin this morning with the
relentless heat wave
pummeling much of the western half of
the country scorching temperatures have
broken hundreds of record highs
more than 75 million people from iowa to
california have been under excessive
heat warnings this week
in california and texas people are being
told to conserve electricity to prevent
rolling blackouts this is all happening
happening during an historic
drought it's making that situation worse
and it's also
increasing the danger of wildfires
jonathan vigliotti is in the town of
helzberg in northern california
jonathan that area has some of the
toughest water restrictions in the
country right now
that's correct anthony good morning and
we're in the heart of wildfire country
and this town's main source of water
has all but dried up businesses and
homeowners here
are being asked to reduce their water by
as much as 40 percent or face fines of a
thousand dollars
all of this as officials are warning the
water here
could run out by the fall that over
there used to be islands
for briana ramirez it's hard to believe
this
is the same lake her family used to take
their boat out on
we need water to survive and it's scary
it really is
severe lack of winter snow and rain and
this week's punishing heat wave
have transformed lake mendocino into a
desert
causing ramirez to rethink how she uses
the water she does have
we're telling your kids hey you can only
take this amount long of a shower
cutting back you know loads of laundry
across 12 states tens of millions of
americans have endured sweltering
temperatures of 100
or above this western state heat dome is
a dramatic reminder
that mother nature bats last and she
bats a thousand but with the first day
of summer
still days away another big concern for
brianna ramirez
is fire season last year flames
destroyed more than
4 million acres across california
setting a new record
this year's excessive heat is already
fueling brush fires throughout the state
lake mendocino was once a reliable
source with water
to dump on flames it seems like this
really highlights
what is going to be a volatile wildfire
season for you during the past
seasons we've sat here i've sat here
with my kids and watched the planes
pick up water out of the lake you know
and there's nothing
makes me wonder is this what we have to
look forward to is it going to recover
from this
and temperatures across parts of the
west will exceed 110 degrees one doctor
warning the surfaces
could get so hot touching them for even
a fraction of a second
could cause second to third degree burns
tony
incredible very troubling pictures there
jonathan bigliotti for us jonathan thank
you very much